نشره من تطورات اعتقال السلطات الروسيه
لصحفي يعمل لدى صحيفه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان واشنطن تشعر بقلق بالغ ازاء
الانباء عن احتجاز روسيا لصحافي امريكي
يعمل لصالح صحيفه
البيت الابيض ناشد المواطنين الامريكيين
مغادره روسيا على الفور وقال ان السفاره
الامريكيه في موسكو تواصلت مع الخارجيه
الروسيه سعيا لتمكين
من الخدمات القنصليه من جهه نقل التاسعه
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه انه سمح
لصحفي المعتقل بالتواصل مع قنصليه بلاده
وكان الكرملين قد قال ان اعتقال مراسل
صحيفه
لا يتعلق بالاشتباه به مشيرا الى القاء
القبض على المراسل متلبسا بالتجسس وعما
اذا كانت موسكو ستتعاون مع وكالات
المخابرات الامريكيه في القضيه قال
المتحدث باسم الكرم لاند ماتريبي ان
القراره من صلاحيات جهاز الامن الفيدراليه
الروسي بدورها قالت متحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان نشاطه مراسل وست
جورنال في مدينه يا كاترين بورد لا يمد
بصله للعمل الصحافي وقد نفد صحيفه
الاتهامات التي وجهت لمراسلها في موسكو
تنضم الينا الى ان من واشنطن المراسله
الجزيره وجد وقفي معنا كذلك من موسكو مدير
مكتب الجزيره زاور شاوش ماذا في تفاصيل
هذا
الاعتقال وهذا الاتهامات الموجهه للصحفي
ماذا يقول الكريمينال في ذلك
السجن الذي تطبع يقبع به الان
قررت ابقاءه
رهن الاعتقال
في اطار التحقيقات وطبعا في حال ثبتت هذه
التهمه على الصحفي الامريكي الذي يعمل لدى
جورنال فانه قد يواجه حقوقك تصل الى 20
عاما
بالسجن تحت بند التجسس في القانون القضائي
الروسي حسب ما قالت المتحدثه باسم وزيره
وزاره الخارجيه روسيا زخرفه فان الاتصالات
متاحه
[موسيقى]
البيت الابيض عن تواصل السفاره الامريكيه
مع الخارجيه الروسيه ماذا في الجهود
الامريكيه والى اين وصلت
دعم ايمان قبل قليل انهى جون كيربي منسق
لاتصالات استراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
احاطه لنا الصحفيين طبعا
واوضح بان البيت الابيض مسؤولون من البيت
مسؤولين من البيت الابيض والخارجيه
الامريكيه تواصلوا بدايه مع الصحيفه وايضا
مع عائله ايفان
وكذلك تواصلوا مع الخارجيه الروسيه وذلك
من اجل ضمان
ايجاد تواصل ما بين ايفان وكذلك السفاره
الامريكيه بحسب كيربي بحسب البيت الابيض
والخارجي الامريكيه حتى الان لم تتح فرصه
التواصل ما بين
ايفان
والسفاره الامريكيه في موسكو وحسب ما اكد
كيربي بان الاداره الامريكيه ما زالت
تحاول التواصل مع الح الروسيه من اجل ضمان
اتصال السفاره الروسيه ورؤيتها
لغرفتش طبعا ادانا شديده باشد العبارات
نقلها البيت الابيض لاعتقال الصحفي
غوغوفيتش وكذلك نفي قاطع من قبل صحيفه
فرضتها او تحدثت عنها الحكومه الروسيه
واكدت بانه كان موجودا هناك بطبيعه عمله
كصحفي الخارجيه الامريكيه حقيقه وكذلك
البيت الابيض
شددوا جميعهم قبل قليل على ضروره ان
يستجيب
المواطنون الامريكيون
لمناشدات الخارجيه الامريكيه بعدم السفر
الى روسيا وبالنسبه للامريكيين الموجودين
في روسيا ضروره المغادره على الفور
سئلت بما اذا كان اعتق ال اذا هو تصعيد من
قبل روسيا ام لا لم يشا الاجابه وقال حتى
الان
اسباب اعتقاله الاسباب الحقيقيه وراء
اعتقاله ما زالت غير معروفه بالنسبه
للاداره الامريكيه شكرا